let's go where do we want to go next
let's go to the five-seven one area code
who's calling today from 571 hi David
can you hear me yes I can
all right hi this is Krishnan from
Northern Virginia hey how are you I'm
doing well how are you good
so I wanted to talk to you about so I
want to get us out just for a fourth
ride I'm an Elizabeth Warren supporter I
started out supporting her then when she
was not doing well in the polls I
decided to switch to Bernie but when she
started gaining momentum I was like yeah
I really connect with the way she's
messaging and her policies and her
approach to her campaign okay
and so I'm solidly with her gun so the
thing I wanted to address is first of
all I really appreciate you're very fair
and objective critiques analysis of and
comparisons with her and other
candidates but what they I wanted to
address is people say that what at one
critique of Warren that I hear over and
over again is that she's going to take a
big money or corporate money in the
general election which she admitted if
she gets a nomination which he admitted
to I agree about that but they say
Bernie won't and you said that too and I
haven't seen any source that says that
he will not take big money in the in the
general election because he did take big
money as a Senate candidate in 2018 just
as warranted in fact he and Warren
raised the same amount in large dollar
donations in 2018 and they transferred
the same amount to their presidential
campaign correct so I'm not sure why
we're saying I I just I just want to get
it out that we should be very fair in in
comparing those two do you have you seen
anything that contradicts what I'm
saying or do you agree well listen I so
I don't have a source in front of me so
my understanding was that previously
Bernie Sanders had said he will not take
the money at any level of the campaign
now it sounds like what you're saying is
you've not seen that said definitively
and so therefore it would not be
illogical to presume that he might in
the general election but he's simply not
talking about it is that more or less
what you're suggesting yeah that's what
I'm suggesting and what I'm saying is if
he were if he did not take that pledge
if he did the same thing warranted like
leave it open
general yeah I would be okay with that
because general elections are extremely
expensive and Trump is going in and with
a massive fundraising advantage what do
you think about that I know I've said
before that I think it is great for
candidates to decide not to take money
of whatever sources they don't want to
take it at any point I do think that in
the general it's not crazy to make the
argument that if you unilaterally disarm
by saying I'm not gonna take the money
that you are setting yourself up to lose
and then we're all worse off because
then Trump gets reelected so III don't
have a super strong position one way or
the other I can see both sides of it but
I'm not someone who's going around
smearing Warren because she plans to do
it in the general I think that you
greatly diminish your chances of winning
if you don't I I completely understand
and thank you very much for that and
yeah all right that's it that's what I
want to know all right thank you
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you